- Good day, good people.
Wow, it's amazing to be here.
It's such a great venue
with you all in person.
Thanks for joining us.
Quick show of hands, how many
of you are building AI agents?
Almost everyone, right?
Sure.
How many of you have deployed
agents in production?
Wow, okay, perfect.
Most of you guys.
All right, how many of you
are developing MCP tools?
Lot of them, great.
And then how many of you
have more than 10 MCP tools?
More than 10.
Few, 25%, Okay.
More than 50 MCP tools,
just two folks.
All right, excellent.
Thank you.
So you are gonna be
learning in this session
how to scale from those first few tools
to thousands of tools
across hundreds of agents
securely at enterprise grade
without operational headache.
My name is Dhawal Patel,
I'm the global lead
for solutions architecture
team in generative ai.
And let's dive in into this topic.
So
across industry verticals,
across multiple companies
and industry verticals
like healthcare,
finance,
security operations,
observability and many more,
companies are transforming their customer
experience using agentic ai.
And we are really honored to
have one of our customers,
Sumo Logic, who's gonna share our journey,
their journey in agentic AI in security
operations space in this session.
So I'm really looking forward
to their story as well.
But here's the thing,
your AI agents needs real data.
Your data, the data could be
sitting in knowledge basis,
private data stores, enterprise APIs,
or even the data could be sitting on prem.
The magic happens right there,
agent to tool, data integration layer.
This is really critical for you to scale.
In order to scale and be able to succeed
in your agentic AI
success, in your journey.
So let's dive in.
Why?
So
let's imagine that you are developing
a customer support agent for retail,
and the users are basically able
to shop, they're able to get the support,
check the order status, and
then you develop this great POC
and works great with few
of your user queries.
You are excited about it, your
stakeholders are impressed
and now they ask you to deploy
it in production at scale.
That's when the reality hits.
Now you think about scaling
from those first few users
to thousands of users.
You need to also manage
the infrastructure scaling.
But hey, before that you
need to make sure that
your AI agents can talk to real data,
your data,
and can integrate with
your enterprise APIs.
So that you can accurately
respond, your agents,
to respond to the user
queries with right accuracy
and without hallucinations.
How do you do that?
So
what you do then
essentially is well you say
let me integrate with some of
my existing enterprise APIs
that could help my customer support agent
like product catalog and then pricing
and then customer details.
And then you slowly and steadily,
you try to integrate these tools
with your AI agent and
then why just only APIs?
Then you think about like,
let me also integrate my MCP
tools or MCP servers as well,
or maybe talk to other AI agents as well,
as agents, as tool pattern.
So now you try to decouple
the agents and tools to scale.
And so now you have
this great architecture
where you have a clear distinction
between agents and tools.
Now
you might have
20,
30,
tools to manage.
Still manageable, right?
Well let's see how.
So now you have your other
team members onboarding,
developing different other
agents like pricing agent,
shopping agent or essentially
maybe that you try
to decompose that large
customer support agent
into manageable specialized agents.
Or maybe you have different use case
or maybe you're developing
new product features
and now you have these
N-number of agents to manage
with M-number of tools to manage
with that M cross N
exponential growing complexity to manage.
And that's exactly why
you need to scale this.
And you have the protocols
like model context protocol,
which you are all aware of
and which really takes care
of inter-operability
and making sure that
you have this unified communication
between the agents and the tools.
However, this is clearly not enough
because you still have
this sprawling architecture
where you still have these agents
talking to these number of tools
and you need to handle the governance,
you need to handle the
fine-grain access control,
you need to handle the security
and you need that single
communication unified point.
Where you can govern all these things
and scale at enterprise level, right?
And then think about it, when
your customer base grows,
you're gonna have a lot
of users, maybe thousands,
maybe hundreds of thousands of users.
And then you are gonna have
these different personas
of these users accessing these agents
and then bring this
multi-tenancy into the play
where you're developing
these agents as service.
And now you have to
manage these tenants like
hundreds of tenants.
So you have these different
permutation combinations
of fine-grain access control
of who gets to access
which tools, is really a lot
of heavy lifting for you to manage.
In this diagram, what I'm
showing is a pricing agent is
same, but being accessed
by two different users.
You want one of those users
or some of those users to have access
to promotional discounts while
you don't want other users
to have access to those
promotional discounts.
How do you do that?
How do you do that
dynamically as well, right?
You need to scale that as well.
So here's the thing,
you start with business use case.
You start with the user queries,
you define your agent goals,
you decompose your agent goals
into manageable agentic tasks
and then walk backwards
and identify existing
enterprise APIs or data that you can use
to satisfy the agentic tasks.
And then as you continue
working backwards,
you identify those data custodians
and the existing microservices
that can satisfy those task
and then map it out, work backwards,
in identifying the right MCP
targeted tools for our agents.
And then what you end up
with is lots of MCP servers,
maybe hundreds of MCP servers now.
And then you have these on the other end,
like lots of agents,
maybe hundreds of agents
accessing this thousands of MCP servers.
It's clearly a lot of
heavy lifting, again.
You're gonna have to
manage the infrastructures,
scaling, containerization
of these MCP servers.
A lot of heavy lift for you, right?
What do we do, what's the answer?
Well before we go into the
solution, here's the thing.
You need to scale maybe
at hundreds of agents
with thousands of tools,
with hundreds of MCP servers
to manage, with these different
types of API types to manage
and MCPify them.
And then these...
Add this multi-tenancy into the mix.
Probably you're gonna end up
having hundreds of thousands
of tenants,
with hundreds of thousands
of permutation combinations
of tools policies to manage, dynamically.
How do we scale?
What you really need is
a single,
unified,
communication point
for all of your
agent-to-tool interactions.
And when I say tool, I just
don't mean only the APIs
or data stores,
I also mean other agents as well.
Acting as the tool as
well, for the other agents.
And what you really need to
have is a very fast, quick way
of MCPfying your existing APIs.
You need to have purpose
build features like tools,
semantic tools discovery,
fine grain access control,
integration with authorization,
maybe also integrating with
your existing IDP solutions
for authorization,
integration with observability,
and don't forget the evaluations.
This is what you need in order to scale.
And that's exactly how we built
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore gateway.
So Amazon Bedrock AgentCore Gateway
offers the single unified
communication point.
It's a purpose built AI
gateway for all of your
agent-to-tool interactions
with one click MCPification
of your existing enterprise APIs.
You can also MCPify your
AWS Lambda functions.
You can also integrate
your existing MCP servers
and unify that in that unified endpoint.
It does all of that heavy lifting
of MCP protocols handshake
for you so that you're not
in the business of managing,
upgrading your containers
and servers to new protocol versions.
And then think about the
fine grain access control.
Think about all the problems
that I shared before, right?
You need to scale as an
M-cross-N complexity increases.
It's completely serverless, pay as you go.
And you can also connect
from your private VPC
and have a secure communication
with your MCP gateway
with your AgentCore gateway.
Alright, so I'm gonna hand it over to Nick
to further dive deep into
AgentCore Gateway features.
Thank you.
- Hello, can everyone hear me okay?
Okay, fantastic.
So my name is Nick Aldridge,
I'm one of the principal engineers
in the agentic AI org at AWS.
I've been at Amazon for about seven years,
worked on a bunch of AI
products like Amazon Lex,
Amazon Bedrock.
I've led the team that
built knowledge bases
and now I helped create AgentCore.
I also happen to be one of
the core maintainers of MCP
and I serve on the steering
committee of A-to-A.
So what I want to do is
dive a little bit deeper
into some of the things
that Dhawal mentioned
and talk a bit about how this
works from a technical lens.
So what you see on the screen
is a high level architecture
diagram of the gateway, right?
And you can see that gateway is acting
as this intermediary like
Dhawal mentioned, right?
Where on the left hand
side you see your agent,
which is in theory interacting
with other agents and tools
and resources, right?
And the gateway is really acting
as an intermediary like I said.
And also as a translator,
it's providing a standard
interface for all of those tools,
APIs and agents to talk to.
And the cool thing is those
tools, APIs and agents
can live on any cloud, right?
They might be on GCP,
they might be on AWS,
they could be running on EKS
or they could be running on EC2.
Gateway is fronting all of those things.
So on the left hand
side you can see Gateway
is providing a few operations,
list tools, search tools, invotool.
These are standard MCP operations.
It's also providing a standard
authorization interface, right?
So you can decide whether
you want to use OAuth or IAM,
but Gateway will perform that
standard authorization check,
it will talk to your identity
provider if necessary
and then it will perform routing.
So it will figure out, hey,
is the API I need to talk to
running on this server or that server,
and it will make the appropriate call
with the appropriate credential.
So it will also perform
a credential exchange
and all of those calls
will have standard logging and auditing.
So as a business
who wants to solve some specific
business problems, right?
I can use Gateway to not worry
about the integration points.
I can use Gateway just
to give my developers
who are building agents
that standard interface
so that they can just
focus on the agent building
and Gateway can manage
the integration points.
Now there are different ways
that you can provide these tools, APIs
and agents to the Gateway.
One way you can provide them
is by hooking up a Lambda function.
So you can hook up any
arbitrary Lambda function
and Gateway will be able to
expose that Lambda function
as an MCP tool, or group of MCP tools,
and Gateway will be able to
do the translation necessary
to authorize to that Lambda function
by assuming this IAM role.
All the while you're
getting, sort of, that log
and auditability that I talked about.
Something similar works for APIs.
Now when I talk to customers
about open API specs,
they often think about these
as existing APIs that are sort
of production grade, right?
This is not necessarily a spec
for a production grade API.
This could be a spec that
defines the input to your server
that's running on EKS
with Kubernetes, right?
It could be an API spec for
something that's running on GCP.
It could even be a spec
for another company's API,
which you don't own.
And all of those API specs can
be hooked up to the gateway.
You can choose from different
credential types like API key,
OAuth token,
and then Gateway will
again provide that sort of
standard interface to
those APIs for your agent.
The third way you can provide APIs
and tools is a Smithy model.
Smithy specification.
This may not be a
familiar term to you all,
but this is how we define APIs at AWS.
We use this specification called Smithy.
And so the amazing thing
about this integration is
there are 400 plus AWS services
that offer these Smithy
specifications on GitHub.
So you can actually take
those specifications,
plug them into Gateway
and get an interface to any of the APIs
that those services use.
So suddenly your agents can
do things like download files
from S3 buckets, they can
execute jobs on transcribe
and do all sorts of other things.
So this is an incredibly
powerful integration
and one that a lot of teams in AWS
are also very excited about.
Now we had those integrations
and we were excited
about those integrations
and customers told us,
Hey, that's all well and good
but I have some MCP servers
in my organization today,
plus I have MCP servers
outside my organization
that I want to connect with.
And ideally I want your fancy
gateway thing to compose all
of them in a single interface.
And so in response to that problem,
we launched MCP server as a target.
And what MCP server as a target does
is it lets you attach any MCP server,
as many as you want to a gateway.
And we will fill all of their tools
in the list of tools alongside
the API spec ones, et cetera.
When a customer invokes a tool,
we'll invoke the corresponding
tool on the MCP server
and we even support
search over those tools
and we'll talk about how that works.
Now, when you are
listing tools, we do this
by caching the tool
schema of all of the tools
that your APIs and MCP servers expose.
So Gateway first caches
all of those tools.
Your agent can ask,
Hey, give me the list and will respond
to the list even without making
additional downstream calls.
The agent can then decide
it wants to invoke a tool
and Gateway will
facilitate that invocation
while also doing the
appropriate credential exchange.
And as I mentioned,
gateway will offer search.
So it will rely on this
cached copy of tools
to create an internal index
which it's actually able
to search in real time in
response to an agent query.
And what this unlocks is that,
rather than giving an agent
a list of a few hundred tools,
let's say, you can actually give it
just the appropriate list of
the 10 most relevant tools.
Now there are two ways
that Gateway actually
does this synchronization of your toolset
and the entire fact that we
cache tool sets is something
that is based on feedback
from customers as well.
Customers told us,
Hey, I don't want the tools
to be dynamically changing under the hood.
I want those tools to be static.
I want to control which tools are exposed,
when they're exposed, what
the interfaces are, right?
I want to evaluate those
interfaces on my agent
and make sure I'm getting
the appropriate accuracy.
So we cache those tools.
One way we do that is
implicit synchronization.
So whenever you change a target,
whenever you update a target,
we cache the tool set.
The other way that we let you do this
is something called
explicit synchronization,
where you can explicitly invoke this API
and we will look at all
of the tools available
on your MCP server and cache them
so that they can be used in
search and listing et cetera.
Now to dive a little
deeper on search, right?
As I mentioned, a lot of
customers are building MCP servers
with a lot of tools.
At the beginning a bunch
of you raised your hand
that you had, you know, dozens
of tools in your MCP servers
and that will likely increase, right?
As you continue to scale
up your applications,
you'll have more and more tools.
And what we found from
customers is when they had more
and more tools, it was
bloating their context window.
So they had these agents which
suddenly had like 300 tools
and we're spending hundreds
of thousands of tokens
of context on just loading up the tools,
which was not only high
latency and very expensive
but also impacting accuracy, right?
The agents were not able
to orchestrate effectively
over so many tools.
And so we introduced
this thing called search
and I think we may have
even been first to market
with this feature where we
allow you to call a search tool,
and get back the 10 most relevant tools.
Obviously this drastically
reduces latency and cost
and improves accuracy.
It also is pretty
remarkable that we are able
to do this across so many targets, right?
We are managing all that heavy lifting
of pulling in all the tools from all
of the different targets
so that you can search them together.
Otherwise, if you hook up
many servers to your agent,
it will have to sort of
do search across them,
which is complicated.
The other thing that
customers told us is, hey,
if I'm gonna have a unified
layer that's gonna integrate
with all my agents and tools
and resources, then I am
absolutely going to need this
to connect to my VPC.
And so we quickly launched
private link integration
so that you can actually communicate
with this gateway over the
secure AWS network backbone
so that traffic is never going out
to the public internet to
go talk to this gateway.
As important as secure
inbound connectivity is,
secure outbound connectivity
is just as important, right?
I want to be able to
access APIs that may live
inside of EPC.
And so with our Lambda integration,
you can actually call any API in any VPC
and have that call, again,
go over the secure AWS network backbone
so you can have this entire
life cycle of requests
that never actually go
over the public internet.
Now
the reason I think Gateway is
so amazing is I really think
that the protocols are going
to become like TCP/UDP.
In other words, our
developers are not going
to be diving deep into protocols like MCP
in the future, right?
And I think that
I will want my stack
to be continuously cross-cloud,
cross-framework, et cetera.
And I will want a infrastructure product,
a basic product that can solve
all of that integration stuff.
And so in this picture you can see
just how powerful gateway is.
We've hooked up AWS services, right?
A private MCP server
which is running in A VPC,
A private agent, which
is running in A VPC,
another AgentCore gateway
that another team in our
organization has built.
Public MCP servers, which we
may have discovered online.
and then APIs, some of
which may be running
on AgentCore runtime or maybe
running on EC2, et cetera.
And we're able to expose all of that
in this single interface.
Diving a little bit deeper, right?
On how we do this authorization thing
because this is part of the magic.
We offer two types of
ingress authorization,
like I mentioned.
One is Oauth, and the awesome thing
about the OAuth integration is
it uses your proprietary IDP,
your proprietary identity
provider to do authorization.
So when a caller tries
to access a gateway,
gateway will say,
Hey, you need to go talk
to authorization server X,
which you all own.
And then the client can go talk
to that authorization server,
get an access token,
and then make calls through the gateway,
which the gateway will authorize
against your identity provider.
So you sort of have this complete loop,
which can be using your
proprietary identity provider,
instead of IAM.
The other approach for those of you
that are deep in the IAM
ecosystem is to use IAM.
So gateway supports IAM
and you can call with IAM.
And we really did this in response
to customers who were saying,
Hey, like I love IAM today.
I use, IAM for a bunch
of my machine to machine communication.
And so we said that's fine,
we know MCP doesn't support IAM today.
We added IAM support to the gateway
and we actually launched a secure proxy
that you can run on the client side
to make your MCP client,
IAM or Sigv4 compatible.
And you can discover
that on GitHub as well.
The other thing that customers
started telling us was,
Hey, I want to expose gateway
in front of my real end users,
and those end users may not be off.
I might want to make this thing public.
And so we actually ended up launching
a mode of gateway that does not have off.
In fact many of you may have seen
that AWS launched an MCP
server for our documentation.
It uses no off gateways
to make that public
documentation available.
We'll also see later how
you can integrate this
with a custom lambda authorizer
to run your custom off only.
on the egress side, right?
I mentioned that we do
secure credential exchange.
So on the egress side, what
gateway's essentially doing
is picking the correct
token to call the downstream
by calling our AgentCore identity service.
And that service is responsible for
securely storing your credentials,
whether those are API keys,
OAuth tokens, et cetera.
And also caching the actual access tokens.
So that when you make
those downstream calls,
you don't have the off-fatigue
of continuously offing your users again
and again for accessing
the same downstream API.
Now that was all sort of well and good,
but when we talked to most
of our customers, they said,
Hey, we have fine grain access
control logic we wanna run.
we have multi-tenant scenarios
that require us to
implement some custom logic.
We want to prefill some parameters
and not prefill other parameters, right?
And so in response to
this overwhelming demand,
we launched, last week,
something called interceptors.
And interceptors are groundbreaking
because they allow you
or your central teams to
run some standard logic
in between the agent invocation
and the tool invocation.
So that allows you to do things like
fine grain access control.
It allows you to do things
like filtering of parameters
or schema translation or things like this.
So it's an incredibly powerful feature
and it's powered by Lambda, today.
So this is kind of the
architecture diagram
of how this looks.
Essentially a request comes in
and we first pass it through this lambda,
which gets the MCP request
and outputs another MCP request,
which can be totally mutated
or the Lambda can even say,
Hey, this caller is not
authorized to access this tool,
sorry.
If the request is authorized,
we'll actually invoke the target, process,
get back the result and send the result
through the lambda as well.
And you can choose
whether to do this or not.
But then on the results side,
you can also do filtering
or inject additional
parameters or things like that.
So it's an incredibly powerful feature
and this is what it would look like
if you just did it for
fine grain access control,
right?
So in this case, I'm
gonna run that lambda,
I will look at the
caller OAuth information,
which we provide.
I'll look at the tool name and I'll say,
okay, this caller is in finance group
and they're trying to
access a non-finance tool.
Denied, right?
Or this caller is allowed
to access this tool.
Okay fine, and I'll let it through.
They can also kind of do this
in conjunction with list tools.
So when they use this feature
in conjunction with list tools,
they can decide independently
whether they want to run the
Lambda on list tools or not.
In this case, what we're
showing is they're not
running the Lambda on list tools.
So the list of tools is sort of public
and the lambda is running
only on invocation.
Essentially only preventing you
from incorrectly invoking a tool
which you don't have access to.
But alternatively you could
run this lambda on list tools as well.
So you could actually
filter out tools proactively
that the caller will not have access to
or you could proactively remove
parameters which you don't
want the agent to fill.
So it gives you just a totally
newfound control over the
interface you are providing to the agent.
And you can make it totally custom.
This also works for search,
so you can also filter that search list,
so that it's only the tools
which the caller has access to.
And many customers are
interested in using this
for things like token propagation,
they wanna actually inject
their own downstream token
and take over some of that
secure credential exchange.
You can do that too, right?
Your Lambda can add this thing in pink,
this authorization
header with a new token,
so that they can do
federated calls downstream.
So this is, I think, really a game changer
and really helping
customers to actually take
this thing live in production.
And the last thing I wanna quickly mention
is we are continuously
hearing from customers
that setting up your tool set to expose it
to an agent is actually
pretty hard, right?
Nobody wants to expose their APIs as is.
Everybody wants to write
some code on top of them
and then you have to, you
know, edit your descriptions
and figure out the right
format and all the stuff.
So we actually built a custom
agent which helps you do that.
This custom agent, which you
can find on GitHub, walks you
through the process of getting
a schema which is useful
to an agent, which is valid, right?
From whatever internal
schema you may be using
and which can actually
be integrated in Gateway.
So this really, really simplifies
the onboarding process.
And so I know that was
a lot of information
and with that I want
to turn it over to Kui
to talk a little bit about how Sumo Logic
has deployed this in production,
how they're solving some
of these problems for real.
Thanks.
- Thank you Nick.
Great presentation to
kick off the use case
of AgentCore Gateway as well as dive into
the nuts and bolts of how
AgentCore Gateway works.
We like AgentCore and for
the next 15 minutes or so,
I'm gonna take you guys
through our journey
to agentic AI using
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
So how many, can I take
a quick show hands,
how many people heard or
used Sumo Logic before?
Okay, how many of you have
solved the reliability
and observability issues
with your workload,
show of hands?
And how many of you have worked
with the security investigation?
Things like a triage or
investigation for vulnerabilities?
Okay, cool, that's a good...
Good ratios here.
I like all the agentic AI builders,
this is our experience.
Like to share how we did that.
And actually before I show the demos,
I want to give a little
highlight about Sumo Logic.
We are leading cloud scale
intelligent operation platforms,
and we are born in AWS
cloud, 10 years ago,
and right now we're running
on 10 AWS regions worldwide.
And just give you a sense of our scales.
We ingest, net new telemetry data,
multi-petabytes of data
ingestion every day,
and multi-exabyte of data scan every day.
That gave you a sense of the
scale Sumo logic can handle.
We have a hundred...
We have a thousands of
enterprise grade customers
and the demo I'm gonna show
you is how our agent works.
I'm gonna show you two
part of the experience.
The first part is there are
several autonomous investigation
agents working simultaneously
and secondly I want to show you
beyond autobox, beyond going
to Sumo Logic consoles,
how to leverage your everyday apps,
how the agent works seamlessly
with your day-to-day apps.
And thanks for AgentCore Gateway.
Alright, let's, let's show the demos.
Can everyone hear the voice?
Good?
Okay, thank you.
- [AI] Sumo Logic Dojo AI running on
Amazon Bedrock agent code.
Here we have the Sumo
Logic clouding console
where a number of insight has five alerts.
Before performing any
manual investigation,
the SOC analyst agent has
automatically triaged each insight
with a verdict assigned as
benign, suspicious, or malicious.
Jumping into an insight,
AI investigation details
are immediately surfaced.
Provide concise context to
help understand this event.
All helps to the SOC analyst agent.
Along with the AI verdicts,
the agent recommends
adjusted severity level
using evidence backed reasoning
from inside data signals
and enrichments by synthesizing
the related signals,
a concise narrative style
summary is generated.
Allow analysts to quickly
understand what happened,
who was involved, and why it matters.
Specific detail, key
findings are also presented
providing analysts an immediate
sense of threat impact
with deeper analysis required.
The SOC analyst agent support
hypothesis based investigation
using your log data
and the help of mobile.
Launching directly from insight.
We can begin to use natural
language to investigate further.
Notice that the context of our incidents
is already inherited.
To dive a little deeper, we will go ahead
and ask Mobile to run
a quick investigation.
Leveraging our security
data, the agent will begin
to automatically execute his own analysis
by running several search queries
and summarizing its findings.
With the help of SOC analyst
agent running our AgentCore,
we can bring agentic AI reasoning
directly into your security
operation workflows
and it enable analysts
to effectively capture
the information they need.
Here we have another cloud SIM insight
that has notified us in Slack.
Before requesting more
details about this event,
we will take a look at what
Sumo Logic tools are available
for our MCP server.
Prompting it directly
from our Slack thread.
In the background, our Slack
application is leveraging
an orchestrator agent
hosted on AgentCore runtime,
which then communicate
with AgentCore gateway
via standard MCP protocol.
The AgentCore gateway is fully managed
and is security integrated with
Sumo Logic platform
APIs and Dojo AI agents.
Several actions are ready to use,
like capturing more
details related to insights
and running queries
directly in Sumo logic.
As multi-tool calls are
supported, we will go ahead
and ask mobile to provide
any triage details
that this SOC agent generated
and update the status of
this insight to in-progress,
we quickly see our triage
details summarized,
in response that our
change has been reflected.
To capture more details,
we will request a list
of related entities tied to this event.
Here we can see any user
account, IP, device information
and other entities
associated with this insight.
We can even run search
directly into our raw logs
in Sumo logic,
and see if other users may have
experienced similar activity
in the last three days.
Upon retrieve of the results
from our log search, we see
that other users has
in fact been impacted.
To wrap this up, we'll add
a comments to the insight
stating that other users
appear to be affected.
Hopefully this gave you a clear picture of
how you can leverage
Dojo AI either directly
in Sumo Logic console or from within
your favorite apps and tools.
All thanks to the help of
Amazon Bedrock Agent Corp.
Thank you.
Pretty interesting demo, isn't it?
Yeah.
So for the next couple slides
I'm gonna show you how we build this.
Let me start with a Sumo Logic platform.
From the left hand side, you can see
we ingest our customer's data,
telemetry data for the main
part, regardless where they sit.
Could be in Amazon Cloud, Google Cloud,
whatever clouds you are living in.
seamlessly ingest this
at a super high scale
into our platform.
And then we have a single pane of glass
to operate and monitor
and analyze your data
for your applications.
And then in the middle, as you can see,
we have a rich set of analytics tool sets.
So we automatically convert
the raw telemetry data
into meaningful insights
and recommendation.
So the team can make a decision.
And then on the right hand side,
we have hundreds of autobox
integration for actions.
For example, reporting, ticketing
and remediation
or containment.
So, and last but not least,
the top tier which I
highlight is the Dojo AI.
Is the multi-AI agent
systems that we're building
and are launching this year.
So what is Sumo Logic Dojo AI?
Dojo is a Japanese world to
demonstrate a collections
of intelligence...
... Intelligent personas are
leaving and working together
and learning their skill as they go.
So I think that's a perfect
fit to our agentic AI visions.
So we are..
... Dojo AI in a nutshell,
is a multi-AI agent systems
for proactively doing the security
and incident analysis and response.
So there's the four important principles
when we build Dojo ai.
First we treat a Dojo AI
agent as the digital teammates
for the existing security operation teams.
They can work seamlessly with the humans
and other agent using natural language.
Multi-turn, conversational
natural language interface.
And very, very important why
we decide to use agentic AI
versus just the vanilla generative AI.
Because we want each of our agent
to be fully contextually aware.
they can seamlessly share the
context, update the context
between the agents as
well as automatically
make decisions about
which tool should I use.
And the agent also being smart
to discover tools as we go.
And the tool also being able to access
very important domain
knowledge in our use cases.
So can dynamic access domain knowledge,
and grounded with domain knowledge.
Last but not least, our
agent are secure by design.
So let me show you the architecture about
how this whole things look like.
Let me start with the
Sumo Logic platform tier.
There are three pillars of resources
exposing as MCP based resource.
The first one is what do
we call the platform APIs.
We have hundreds of open APIs, public API,
expose our functionality
of the core data platforms
and then in the middle
this is the new family
of Sumo Logic platforms,
we call it dojo AI foundries.
And as you can see, at this reinvent
we announced three agents (inaudible).
They are our query agent,
and seamlessly translate
the natural language
into highly scalable DSL.
We call the Sumo Logic query language.
And this is where we are
able to run natural language,
ask questions from Slack
or from our console
and then directly compile
into natural language queries,
run and bring the result back,
and summarize in natural language too.
Summarization agent is
another one where (inaudible).
And then the interesting part
about the more autonomous
and SOC analyst agent is where
you see in our triage agent
as well as our investigation agent,
you can fire up a pretty
high level question
to say run a quick investigation for me
or run a deep investigation
and then the agent behind the thing,
leveraging the reasoning models,
able to create a plan, investigation plan
and then generate actionable steps.
Each step can automatically
run by our platform
and bring the result back.
So human is also in the loop about this
which make these things very interesting.
The third pillar is our MCP servers.
So why we need MCP server?
We see there's more and more
new context during the investigation.
We want to be able to expose them
as a resource to the other tiers.
And so this is pretty much
our Sumo Logic platform tier.
And then let's look at our client tier.
The client tier is quite
interesting, as well,
in our default personas we have developers
or the so-called SREs,
they're looking at the code
and then they want to be able
to without leaving their own IDs,
whether it would be a VS code
or cursors or the cloud code.
So they want to be able to
directly our platform APIs
or using our AI agent
remotely through MCP protocol,
which is pretty interesting.
The other part of the
personas is our so-called,
the IT analysts, security analysts.
And they want to stay within
their favorite Slack tool,
for example, they want to be able also
to do it in the same thing.
How can I reach the
powerful Sumo Logic platform
to build the integration use cases.
And each of those are
customers, type of customers.
They're also building
their own custom AI agent.
And last but not least,
look at our Sumo Logic platform
tiers, or the partner tiers.
More and more partners are
also building their own MCP
servers that became publicly
addressed, security managed.
But then we can enable
end-to-end integration
using the using these things.
So we're missing something here.
How to make this super
complex multi-tier cross
org kind of things working together.
How to enable the agent-to-agent
collaboration using MCP.
And the answer is AgentCore gateway.
And so there is two,
at least, there's two integration patterns
enabled by this architecture.
The first one we saw is
coming from the client side.
The client shall be able to reach out
to AgentCore gateway using
the standard MCP protocol
to leverage either our
API or our Dojo AI agents
or reach out to our MCP servers.
The other way, also quite interesting,
our agent using the same patterns
shall be able to reach out
to our...
... Reach ecosystem of
partner tier, leveraging,
for example, Amazon has
launched nearly a hundred
of MCP servers
and there are some multi-hundreds
of very rich kind of tool sets.
And similar for our threat intel partners,
similar for our action
automation partners.
So we can, our Dojo AI
agent can now leverage
their rich ecosystem to build
a very rich integration.
So next I'm gonna take you
to one level step down.
I want to show you three patterns
to how to make these things happen.
The first thing, let's
start with the client tier.
As I said, we have a
Slack app and guess what?
Slack is not super friendly
with AI native things, like a cursor
or VS code so that we build
our client side AI agent just
to emulate how our client,
how our customers are building
their own custom AI agent.
And this AI agent has to be
hosted on AgentCore runtime,
which is a great way to
simplify a lot of things.
So why we need this agent with the tools,
the whole topic for today
is about using reach
data for two chains.
So there's three important capabilities.
We use a line graph to build
this orchestration agent.
The first one is called the planner node
and then we have execution node.
We also have a summarization node.
So now let start to jump in
my first patterns is what are
we call the API as a tool.
So typically there's the two type of APIs.
One is the API exposed
through open API protocols
and AgentCore gateway happens
to natively support this
using open API target
and you have another type
of perhaps a more older
or legacy AI
endpoint
for example using avril or using GraphQL,
those kind of things, we
can use a lambda translator
in between.
So we can translate the protocols
and then wire it up with AgentCore gateway
using the lambda target.
So that's the first pattern.
Expose API as a tool.
The second pattern I want to mention,
expose AI agent as tools.
This is where you see a number of
AI native agentic
AI agents.
They can also, simply
using a lambda target,
you can expose the functionality
through the lambda target
under AgentCore gateway
and then expose them to
the client tier agent.
the client tier agent will be able
to discover the new AI
native functionalities
through this patterns.
And the third patterns, also
I want to be interesting,
we see a growing demands
of MCP servers either
as a third party or as a first party.
So in that case thank you
for AgentCore gateway.
They just have to have did a fantastic job
to do this piece of heavy lifting for us
so we don't have to reinvent the view.
So they have a native MCP target support
as Nick and Dhawal (inaudible)
and even better they have
a better fine grain access control.
So in the case you want to provide
more custom access control policies.
Now the fine grain access
control is your friend.
So those are the three powerful patterns
I want to offer with this audience.
And to wrap up, I want to highlight.
We already adopt several
important AgentCore gateway
features and and patterns on the left.
And we are in the process
of actually working
with this wonderful service teams
from AWS Bedrock AgentCore teams,
to evaluate and testing all
the fine grain access control.
We also working super closely
on the end-to-end OS integrations
and we are also exploring,
looking for the next year,
we are also exploring the
next more advanced features,
how to leverage AgentCore memory features
because I mentioned it's very
important to share memories,
share context across agents,
or DOJO agent families.
And also how to enable
more advanced collaboration
using the A-to-A protocols.
So there's a lot of
exciting things coming up.
Just to wrap up my talk here,
we found AgentCore is a great way for us
as agentic application builders,
we can now focus on our
core value proposition.
We want to build agentic
SecOps intelligence
for our customers.
And just to summarize the business impact
by shipping the AgentCore,
shipping the Dojo AI
via AgentCore, we are able to see about
50% of faster analysis time
up to 75 reduction into so-called MTTR,
mean time to resolution.
And for that we see
millions of dollars saving
from the incidents to happen.
So with that, if you want
to see a lot more demos,
we have a live demo booth in the expos.
Feel free to explore.
Our demo team will show you live demos
and you can try to ask all
kinds of tricky questions.
Our agent will be able
to give you surprise.
Okay, with that, thank
you for the opportunity.
Turning to Dhawal.
- Alright, thank you Kui.
So let's go through the key takeovers.
Some of the best practices I wanna share
as you scale your MCP tools and agents.
Always start with your user queries.
Start with the agentic goals,
decompose your agentic
goals into agentic tasks
and then start working
backwards from identifying
the right set of enterprise
APIs, data stores
and then start MCPifying them.
Do not convert all of your
enterprise APIs into MCP tools.
The agents are autonomous,
non-deterministic
and you wanna make sure these
agents are invoking the right
tools based on your user
queries and agentic goals.
When you create a new MCP
tool, make sure you select,
you create such type of tool to may be
consolidate multiple APIs
into a targeted MCP tool
that is aligned to your agentic tasks.
Alright, now there are lots of questions
about the how do you
improve the performance
of the MCP tools and overall agents?
Well the number one
thing that we must take
into consideration is how
effective your MCP tools
are in driving the accuracy
and reducing the hallucinations
and overall driving the business value
and the agentic goals.
And for that it is extremely important
to have a continuous feedback loop.
How well your agents are
invoking your MCP tools,
how many times these agents
are invoking your MCP tools.
What is the impact of these
MCP tools on the accuracy?
That feedback loop must be closed.
And the way how you do it
is to have those matrix of
the MCP tools
streamed into the AgentCore observability.
And you have that end to
end AgentCore observability
with the traceability
and a full fledged matrix
of understanding how well your agents
are invoking these tools.
Extremely important.
Now talking about the performance.
The performance of the AI agents
are dependent on various
different factors,
but one of the major
factors is the LLM context.
One of the major complaints
from our customers is,
oh well my agents are latent,
they're not responding on time.
And then the first question I ask is,
how many MCP tools does your agent has?
And then how much of the
context size that each MCP tool
bring in and accumulate as
an overall LLM context size,
what's your MCP tool
description look like?
And when I see that, it's like pages
and pages of the MCP tool description.
So be very cautious how you
describe your MCP tools.
Prompt engineer these MCP tools
because you know what
the MCP tool descriptions
are extremely important in
driving the accuracy for sure.
But then it could also
introduce different types
of attack vectors, like command injection,
or tool poisoning, or command control,
or even different types
of prompt injection attacks can happen.
So make sure that you
are very deliberate about
what you put there as part
of the tools description.
And then you can reduce
the LLM context size
by making sure that you have
that effective right size tool
description for all of your tools.
And this is not just it, there are lots
of other factors
contributing to the overall
agentic performance.
Obviously, I'm just trying to just
go through only the tool
specific recommendations.
Now there are other things that
you also should consider while scaling
with your MCP tools.
Security is job zero,
and when it comes to the
security of agentic AI
it's extremely important
'cause they're autonomous
and, again I'm mentioning
it, their non-deterministic.
There are different ways
of handling the security for agents,
the delegation model, as
well as impersonation model.
The impersonation model
is a very well known model
where you trust an upstream service
and then you call the downstream services
by sharing the credentials.
In a typical microservices world.
Well that's not gonna
work out for agentic AI
because these agents are autonomous
and non-deterministic again.
So you need to have this
fine grain access control
with delegation model, where your agents
are acting on behalf of
the end user's persona.
They're assuming the role
dynamically from the end users
and then they're acting
on behalf of the user
without exchanging the
end users credentials
or JWT tokens to the downstream systems.
So make sure you have this act on behalf
or the delegation model in place.
Now in terms of the fine
grain access control,
use gateway interceptors
that Nick introduced
to have the fine grain access control
of who is able to call
which tool dynamically.
And then customers tell me that,
hey, I have these growing
number of agents and tools.
How do I scale?
And the first thing I ask,
do you have a single source of truth
of your enterprise
approved tools and agents
in a single place, as a
single source of truth?
And that's where the agents registry
and tools registry comes into the play.
Whenever your developer
pushes a new MCP tool
or a new agent, have the development
and deployment pipeline
to your MCP registry
or agent registry that does
this tools checking statically
or dynamically when the
tools are being executed.
When I said static tools checking,
check for security vulnerabilities.
(inaudible) problem
or command injection and
tool poisoning, et cetera.
And then make sure you use
the semantic search capability
that Nick walked through,
which is the native feature
within the AgentCore gateway.
When your tools, number of tools grow,
your list tools, MCP
list tools performance
is gonna take a hit.
You are gonna have large
payloads being sent
to your MCP clients.
Use semantic search to take care of that
and improve the performance
of your MCP tools.
So having said that,
there are lots of other best practices
that I wanna just quickly project.
The registry,
the importance of having a
single source of truth for tools
and agents registry, and bring in
this multi-tenancy into the play,
like use gateway interceptors
to isolate these tenants
if you are sharing
the AgentCore gateway
across multiple tenants.
Alright, so here's the getting started.
You can use AWS console or boto3
and A.W.S C.L.I,
and I really recommend you try
AgentCore Starter Toolkits.
The really easiest way to get
started with AgentCore Gateway
and integrating with each
other AgentCore perimeters
as well.
And here's some other bunch of resources,
like there are about 50 plus resources
that you can go and check out.
It's not about, it's not
just about the tutorials,
it's also like end to end use cases.
You'll find lots of use cases
out there in this repository.
And then obviously what Nick
introduced about the schema
repair agent, do check that out.
It'll help you in MCPifying
your existing open APIs
and make sure that your schemas are valid.
All right, thank you very much.
Do not forget to visit Sumo Logic booth
and I really appreciate the time.
If you have any questions, we
are gonna be available outside
of this hall.
Happy to talk, happy to
answer your questions.
Thank you very much.